welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course Benjamin Dixon filling in for
David one last time he will be back on
Monday question did Donald Trump have a
series of mini-strokes last night or is
he just a [ __ ] now you know your mental
health and all that is very serious your
physical health that's very serious so
I'm not I'm halfway making light of this
and and in a sense I'm not because take
a look at this video he he had a really
hard time saying this word and I don't
know if it's because he's just that
ignorant or if something happened take a
look the latest act of resistors is the
op-ed published in the failing New York
Times by an anomalous really an
anomalous gutless coward II just look so
honestly like okay so not taking this so
seriously I feel I feel Dumber after
watching that video I mean I actually
had to pause and and think to myself
anonymous anonymous man it's anonymous
and the reason it's just the way he
messed it up twice I I kind of felt
frustrated for him because I don't know
every now and then you know your brain
gets so full of thoughts and ideas and
and I guess this is me being empathetic
and giving him the benefit of the doubt
maybe I shouldn't and I'm sure you won't
in the comments section so feel free to
just say whatever the heck you want to
say but for me I felt the frustration
because it's sometimes words do get
garbled our are bold our to see they
there's another example but also you
have to calculate into this that Donald
Trump is not a very intelligent man he
does speak at the level of an
eight-year-old this is some an analysis
of his speech said that he speaks at a
level of an eight-year-old so it's quite
possible that the president just doesn't
know how to say the word on the other
hand it's also possible that Donald
Trump has driven himself into such a
fury and a rage over not having control
over his administration part of the new
York Times and I'm this anonymous I'm
sorry I'm just let me stop anonymous
op-ed this week he could be in such a
fury and a rage about that that he's
pushing himself to two levels of stress
that that quite frankly looked like he
may be having a couple of mini-strokes
now I point this out because there's
rumors coming out of the administration
out of the the White House that the
president is on a tirade that he has
lost it over this op-ed and they are
afraid that he's going to have a heart
attack and so anytime you talk about
this level of anger and rage
uncontrollable rage you really are
talking about someone pushing themselves
to a heart attack or a stroke and those
things you know you notwithstanding the
fact that Donald Trump is a disgusting
human being you know he's still a person
and you know I would hate to see him
push himself to anyway yeah I would I
would hate to see himself allow his
anger to push him to something like a
stroke or a heart attack but it would be
something of his own creation because
it's fueled and driven by his own
narcissism his desire for absolute power
and his desire to have absolute loyalty
from people around them and if you have
it in you to want to dominate and
control everyone around you like that
and at that high level then you know you
it's very likely that you're going to
drive yourself to a stroke or a heart
attack so I'm curious it could it could
have been both you know in normal times
we would say we would wish the president
well but we're talking about Donald
Trump who sees nothing wrong with his
behavior pattern he sees nothing wrong
and in fact it's not even it's one thing
to make a conscious decision that I'm
going to do this anyway Donald Trump is
the the type of sociopaths and
narcissists that he never comes to that
decision point right so for most of us
normal people we honestly know and make
conscious decisions to do X Y or Z when
it comes to our personality our behavior
and our treatment of other people
I believe Don I mean there's plenty of
other people who have done research on
this Donald Trump is the level of has
such a level of megalomania that he
never considers that and so this is
driving he is driving himself to this
point his inability to control his his
level of embarrassment by people who are
exposing just how ridiculous he is and
how incompetent he is he's had the
ability to hide behind this veil of of a
level of privacy even though he was
always in the public eye he wasn't
scrutinized by the public and now he
can't handle that and that's pushing him
to where he is now to where he can't
save you know a four syllable word like
Anonymous